first of all how significant do you
think these protests around the world
could turn out to be well my hope is
that they are very significant or to not
to be very significant in moving many
conversations many uncomfortable
conversations that people on both sides
of that ethnic divide have been a band
ready but we now see and recognize the
need to have them what then happens what
will make it significant is how
everybody else responds what do our
boardrooms look like what do our
political representation look like going
forward that's that's the most important
aspect to this know that they recognize
the the value in an understanding and
and eradicating what essentially is a
human rights abuse yeah we've seen it
before haven't we with other black men
killed by police officers Trayvon Martin
Eric garner Michael Brown and nothing
much change there were protests but
nothing much changed why would this be
different do you think this just feels
different on the ground for starters
mark and I think there's a number of
reasons for that so for instance over
the last three or four weeks you've had
armed robbery murdered while while all
for a for a job at the hands of
vigilantes that murder was was swept
under under the carpet at the highest
levels of city government until until it
was exposed so you understand the
cover-up that also goes in and the
protectionism around around law
enforcement in many places here here in
the US following on that you you had
Brianna Taylor shot to death in her own
bed by by by police officers out of
uniform executing executing a warrant
you've had Christian Cooper who had the
police calling him after he rightly asar
a white lady to leash a dog as he as he
lost jested and then finally you you had
George Floyd murdered the hands of
police while the police officer had his
own hands in his pockets and staring
down a camera no
full well that he was he was being
recorded
also Assessor often see mark these
things don't happen in a vacuum a few
weeks prior to that white people took
assault weapons took over government
buildings to demand haircuts if their
signs are to believe it's it's a huge
disparity in what's been demanding and
the justice that they've been afforded
and you're seeing that any two nor three
streets so when you saw what happened to
George Floyd on the streets of the
country that you're now living in what
were your emotions I was heartbroken as
a father I had to have these discussions
with my son about not just about how you
stay out of trouble but the the
underpinning to that is how as a black
man in in the u.s. you stay alive and
how you aren't afforded the same
luxuries the same rights and and it's
terrible that we have to talk about
rights as a luxury for black people here
in the US and and to be careful so as
justice apparent I have to speak to my
kids about what they can and cannot do
in in an effort simply to stay alive and
that's it that's a tough conversation
for any parent to have regardless of
what the issue is and I mean you've got
a twelve-year-old son I think I'm right
in saying so you've been talking to him
about the images that he's no doubt been
seeing on television yes I've been
speaking to my son my wife and I have
five kids four girls and a boy
our boys are young as 12 eldest girl is
23 now and we've got quite a few in
between so we've been having to have
these conversations on a number of
different levels as I mention from from
a 12 year old all the way up to a 23
year old and and what programs and how
they can all affect change firstly with
with their own communities with their
own friends how they can have those
conversations and move those discussions
forward in better effecting and
mobilizing our local communities who I
freely hold my hands up and admit my
majority Caucasian but we have to have
these conversations we have to have
these efforts in moving in moving them
forward
so it's it's it's been a tough and
testing time yeah I also my wife and I
also went into Boston to join in one of
the marches and to see the diversity and
the youth amongst us you you it lifted
that burden off of my shoulder and you
realize that it's it's in very good
hands
young people of today will change this
world yeah Shaka we're just gonna show
you some pictures while I talk to you
and these are live pictures I think of
the of a memorial service taking place
in Houston in Texas right now that's
where George Floyd grew up and lived
before he moved to Minneapolis and
people filing past his coffin but the
protests here
shaaka have become more than about
George Floyd about races are more
broadly in Britain you've lived in both
countries is there a different
experience to racism
in these countries of course there are
some differences but then there are far
too many similarities and I think that
see that that's the unifying force here
also and not just in the US or in
Britain you've seen you've seen this
protest pretty much the world over and I
think what that speaks to Marcus is that
as much as the death of George Floyd has
been a spark and as much as we will be
carrying science about black lives
matter this ultimately is a human rights
issue and when the human rights of black
people are affected the human rights of
the LGBTQ community are affected the
human rights of women of asylum seekers
of immigrants are similarly affected and
so there there's been a unity in in that
voice and in the in the groundswell and
and we have to we also have to recognize
our own responsibilities or some
discussion with my wife last night
about our responsibilities as as black
people to go out and support the Latino
community to go out and support the
LGBTQ community we are easy to forget
and in the middle of Pride Month here
here in the US we have to go out and
support
all these marginalized communities
because ultimately the underpinning of
all of this is human rights and when we
all uplift each other's human rights we
all benefit okay and just finally what
about football what responsibilities and
I'm thinking here in the UK what
responsibilities do the authorities have
to be part of the answer to this what
should they be doing about racism in
fuggin continue to support the players
who are speaking up as we see but you
can go further in terms of implementing
problem implementation of of the Rooney
rule also what does the diversity of
boardrooms of football clubs look like
what is the diversity of the within the
the offices of the Premier League or the
FA those are things that they can leave
from in the front and lead by example
okay and just in 20 seconds would you
like to see Premier League players take
the knee in the first Premier League
games that are about to start in 10 days
time behind closed doors I certainly
would I think the symbol is the the
symbolizing will be huge and impactful I
also would like to see football clubs
and Premier League footballers continue
long after you've gotten off in the all
right it's good to talk to you shaking
his lock thank you very much indeed